First of all, is there specific hormonal support for somebody on their monthly cycles but has heavy cycles?
So hormonal support with somebody with heavy cycles, you want to look at...
First of all, anybody's having any type of hormonal issues. It's best to get tested.
So doing a Dutch test, which is a dried urine hormone test, is the best approach to get all your estrogen and progesterone testosterone numbers checked.
Because there's all these intermediate metabolites that you want to look at.
If you're having issues with cycles, if you're having issues with getting pregnant, if you're having any type of hormonal...
Anything you think that is hormonally based, I'm not talking about your thyroid, because that should be a separate test.
But the Dutch test is the way to go. Getting a Dutch test to look at the balance of all those intermediate estrogens and progesterones and androgens.
And the Dutch test also gives you an adrenal cortisol profile. That's the thing to get checked first.
So before you go into manipulating your hormones that are being careful, anything that you take that's hormonally driven, it isn't just supporting like a nutrition that's supporting the glands.
If you're doing something that is hormonally itself, all your hormones work on a negative feedback loop.
So if you're taking DHA, that works on a negative feedback loop, but that will basically shut down production of DHA in the adrenal glands.
It's a common supplement that's out there that's used by a lot of practitioners, people with adrenal fatigue.
But you've got to be careful taking that because that will shut down your adrenal glands.
So the best thing to do, whatever you're having, any hormonal issues get tested.
Thyroid tests, so your thyroid doesn't specifically control your estrogen and progesterone.
It's a good idea to get that checked on everybody on a regular basis anyhow.
So if you're in one of our courses, do our complete wellness panel.
That gives you a complete bit of all the profile and a complete CDC with differential, some other things that I like to look at.
That can point to different health patterns and it gives you a complete thyroid profile.
So a complete thyroid profile, remember, is not just your TSH, T3 and T4.
It's T3, T4, T3, T3, T4, reverse T3, TSH, thyroid, globular antibodies and TPO antibodies.
So you want to look at that whole big picture when you look at your thyroid plate.